vous avez mis la photo de thibault parce
que thibault il s'est pendu à 12 ans
suite au harcèlement scolaire qui
subissaient et son entrée en sixième
tivo a vécu l'enfer
oui je sais que vous êtes très ému ce
soir vous vouliez absolument venir en
parler dans cette émission je sais que
c'est une journée très importante pour
vous je voulais que ça que thibaut
soient présents avec nous puisque c'est
lui qui a subi toutes ces violences
ensuite nous en tant que parent mais vu
l'issue que sa vue mais
quand on a vécu avec lui cette violence
également ça nous a détruits ça nous a
c'est compliqué cp photo ça représente
thibault avant le collège thibaud était
heureux thibault était juste un petit
garçon plein de vie très curieux très
intelligent avec un esprit dauphine à
une dalle de justice important c'est un
petit garçon qui était très bien
intégrée qui savait prendre ses
responsabilités puisqu'il était joueur
de hand ball mais également jeunes
arbitres et à son entrée au collège
et là il est passé dans une dans un
monde de violence pour lequel je l'avais
pas forcément préparés à prion alors dès
son entrée au 6e donc thibault a vécu
comme je les dis l'enfer menaces de mort
de l'ours noir ce qui est normal alors
comment ça a commencé à d'abord ça a
commencé la deuxième semaine de la
rentrée scolaire par un jeu
d'humiliation il ya 10
bien on va te faire on va te faire un
tour de magie
donc on lui a appris c'est demain on lui
a dit à 3 tu vas voir il ya quelque
chose qui va se passer
effectivement il ya quelque chose qui
s'est passé on a baissé le pantalon
devant toute la récréation on lui a mis
une couche à un coup de balayette et on
l'a tapée à plusieurs reprises et
plusieurs personnes par des coups de
pied donc là j'ai été averti par le
collège puisque des camarades de classe
ont averti du coup les les
la cpe donc mon fils était complètement
abasourdi il a souhaité est quand même
retourné en classe l'après midi et là un
de ses anciens camarades de classe avec
qui il était en primaire lui a fait une
réflexion et pour une fois thibault lui
a répondu puisqu'il n'y avait pas
l'habitude de rétorquer à cette personne
et là ça a été le déclenchement de toute
la suite de violences d'insultés
d'injures de menaces de mort d'agression
physique en réunion parce que cette
personne n'avait pas l'habitude que
quelqu'un ose lui tenir tête
alors il s'est fait tabasser
quotidiennement s'est fait casser le
bras alors il a été au collège comme il
était en betty parce qu'il s'était fait
une entorse par ailleurs il y avait rien
avoir du tout avec le harcèlement il
s'est fait bousculer et là il est tombé
sur le coude il ya une fracture du coude
donc ses camarades petit camarade autres
guy bergenti n'ont rien trouvé mieux que
c'est le bousculer dans les escaliers
parce qu'avec une béquille et un bras
dans le plâtre
c'est extrêmement facile de se mouvoir
comme ça il allait mourir dans les
escaliers on lui a retiré aussi son
attelle pour le frapper donc au lieu de
quatre semaines
de plâtre ça a été vite alors en avril
2018 thibault donc change de collège
on pense que ça va s'arrêter
et voilà le harcèlement reprend enfin
l'autre collège et moins de 2 de preuves
mais chose qui est avéré c'est qu'à la
rentrée scolaire il a souhaité rentrer
dans un dans une association d'une carte
s'appelle louis guillot et thibaut me
disais que il se faisait passer à tabac
et qui se faisait frapper et qui
s'entendait pas avec ce groupe d'élèves
et début novembre il a décidé de quitter
le club alors vous alerter le collège et
l'éducation nationale oui de quelle
façon
alors ça c'était dans le premier collège
puisque je remarque que mon fils va
souvent à l'infirmerie s'étaient
inscrits dans pronote et vous en a parlé
tout de suite de ce qu'ils subissent à
l'école ou pas du tout pas le jeu
d'humiliation oui après le fait qu'il
était menacé oui donc on
on a essayé de joindre le professeur
principal la cpe
ensuite comme son fils devenir un peu
agressif à la maison ceux qui n'avaient
pas l'habitude d'être avec son petit
frère et sa petite soeur
donc je constate un changement de
comportement de la part de mon fils je
constate également que monfils se
réveille à 3 heures du matin ou des
insomnies il fait des cauchemars il est
fils parle en dormant donc il refait sa
journée donc comprendre ce qui se passe
les portes du collège et tous ces
faisceaux emmène chez le médecin pour
voir s'il ya quelque chose qui pourrait
l'aider à mieux dormir
se calmer parce que je vois bien qu'il
est anxieux et que ça va pas quoi et là
il
il annonce aux médecins qu'il a déjà
fait une tentative de suicide
vous le saviez pas non je ne savais pas
ça m'a complètement détruite
j'étais au bout de ma vie à ce moment là
j'ai dit mais pourquoi tu as fait ça ça
va pas du tout comment tu veux que ma -
s'en remettre si tu fais ce genre de
choses c'est impossible
et en fait il s'est arrêté parce que sa
soeur est rentré dans sa chambre à ce
moment là il avait mis un oreiller pour
arrêter de respirer parce qu'il ne
pouvait plus en fait donc là le médecin
fait faire un mot au collège moi j'avais
arty surprenante l'ensemble de l'équipe
pédagogique l'ensemble des enseignants
pour expliquer bas que du coup thibault
allait être suivi est suivi par un
psychologue qui devait plus
d'antidépresseurs parce que ça allait
vraiment pas chez fayard en rendez vous
avec la proviseur du collège à plusieurs
reprises j'ai demandé à la cpi d'avoir
un rendez vous avec la proviseur du
collège a jamais été fait avec le
professeur principal ça jamais été fait
et j'ai obtenu un coup de téléphone
après avoir envoyé un courrier en
recommandé à la proviseure pour avoir un
rendez vous avec copier à l'inspection
académique
alors ensuite il ya la nuit du 20 au 21
novembre
alors je sais que c'est compliqué pour
vous de le raconter
alors pour extraire mon fils de cet
environnement de violence puisque les
agresseur habitait dans la ville et
n'osaient plus sortir de la maison
on allait changer de collège mais ça
changeait pas son état d'angoissé
j'ai réussi à avoir une mutation à plus
de 500 kilomètres donc quand ça s'est
passé moi j'étais à plus de 500
kilomètres de la maison j'étais parti
courir et je vois que mon mari m'a
appelé et là j'entends un hurlement mais
un hurlement
je comprends même pas ce qu'il dit en
fait donc je le rappelle est p thibault
s'est pendu thibault s'est pendu arrête
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
et là j'ai je peux pas y croire c'est
pas possible j'appelle ma mère chez main
va vite je comprends pas j'appelle ma
belle-mère abbazi dépêche-toi thibault
il a un problème il faut aller le sauver
c'est pas possible
et là je m'assois sur les marches des
escaliers et je hurle milieu hurle je
sais même pas comment dirais je sais
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
thibault il n'a pas pu faire ça thibault
il a pu n'ai pas pu faire ça il n'a pas
le cul non c'est vraiment pas jusqu'au
moment où j'arrive à la maison je monte
les escaliers
là les pompiers avaient à langer
thibault sur le lit et là j'ouvre la
porte
les jeux la referme automatiquement
parce que c'est une vision c'est une
vision d'horreur c'est eva comprend
savez votre petit garçon qui est là
allongé la tête complètement déformés
c'est une vision d'horreur
et là vous rouvrez la porte et vous dit
pas si c'est la réalité et la seule
chose que vous voyez c'est la fenêtre
vous avez juste envie c'est de sauter
par la fenêtre c'est sylvie dit je peux
pas rester là je peux pas rester là
c'est pas possible c'est pas c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible
et voyez votre mari et vous avez même
plus envie de rester là vous avez juste
envie de sauter par la fenêtre et que ça
s'arrête
douleur la douleur le trou le puissance
et là on vous dit qu'il faut dire au
revoir à votre fils est la plus caresser
les cheveux pleurer vous n'êtes pas dans
la votre main votre main touche son coup
et là vous sentez
ça presse à un trou noir je suis tombé
dans les pommes très fort témoignage de
karine c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à à
voile à amiens vous questionnez là
dessus parce que c'est sacré on a
l'impression de vivre la scène avec vous
je vous crois qu'il ya c'est celle des
grands parents de mes parents qui sont
extrêmement émus également la question
qu'on a envie de vous poser c'est
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous en voulez à
quelqu'un ce que vous pensez vous auriez
pu éviter ça si vous avez eu un
rendez-vous peut-être plus tôt avec
l'établissement avec les personnes de
l'éducation nationale est-ce que vous
pensez que ça aurait peut être évité ce
drame
si vous l a jamais été entendu nous
avons jamais été entendu par l'éducation
nationale savons pas n'a pas été entendu
puisqu'on n'a pas été reçue on n'a pas
été entendu puisque quand on vous allez
voir le chef d'établissement il vous
explique que c'est votre enfant qui est
dysfonctionnements qui est un
dysfonctionnement que si votre fils il
se fait taper c'est parce qu'il insulte
comme s'il y avait une excuse à se faire
taper si mon fils il insultait c'est
juste qu'il a adopté les codes qu'il
avait en face de lui parce que la maison
il insulté personne ou andy l'insulté
personnes il était très intégrée oui
l'éducation nationale pour moi a failli